il assume le fait d'avoir changé d'avis
ça c'est très habile dans sa
communication au premier acte les
journalistes envie de placer quillan m
pap et face à lui contradictions son
rêve d'enfant ou foncé était celui
d'aller jouer au real de madrid
je reste quand même un joueur de foot et
j'irai pas au delà de cette fonction
bien sûr si on est amené à parler
football j'aime le football à tout le
monde connaît ma passion j'aime discuter
foot parler foot mais j'irai jamais au
delà de ma fonction de joueurs de foot
qui est ce que c'est possible de rester
normal de ne pas prendre la grosse tête
il faut accepter que ça fait partie du
système après on reste quand même des
êtres humains quand je rentrais chez moi
je pense pas à mon salaire du lendemain
ou au prochain match je pense juste à
profiter de la vie avec mes amis avec ma
famille
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
pas la première fois que la question de
la maturité et posé à m ap si on voit
qu'il s'y attend et qu'il anticipe
justement cette difficulté dans toutes
les réponses qu'ils donnent tout au long
de l'interview tout le monde sait que
l'année dernière je voulais partir et
javel intime conviction que c'était là
la meilleure décision possible à ceux à
ce moment là aujourd'hui avait un
contexte qui était différent un contexte
sportif un contexte aussi un contexte
privé mais il ya ce côté aussi
sentimental de se dire que c'est mon
pays et aussi le projet a changé le bleu
le club a envie de changer pas mal de
choses sur le plan sportif et donc ça
m'a donné vraiment cette envie de
continuer parce que je pense que mon
histoire n est pas fini ici que ce soit
sur le plan collectif et même sur le
plan individuel je pense que mon
histoire ici n est pas terminée je pense
que j'ai des beaux chapitres encore à
écrire et c'est cette décision de
respect c'est presque une non décision
parce que finalement il ya un statu quo
mais lycée de transformer ce statu quo
en un événement sportif et surtout
personnelle je suis un français je suis
patriote j'aime mon pays et donc la
conclusion logique c'est que je vais
jouer en france c'est d'utiliser ce
levier justement pour continuer à
justifier quand on réfléchit finalement
au message que bape et le faire passer
c'est que tout a changé mais il ne doit
pas expliquer que tout a changé il a une
nouvelle place c'est sûr et ça a été dit
en long en large et en travers dans la
presse et il va avoir une nouvelle place
au sein du paris saint-germain bras rôle
sportif mais pour autant il veut
expliquer à tout prix le fait qu' il ne
veut pas avoir les pleins pouvoirs elle
reste ici parce que marie lemay l'année
à condition pour réaliser
nos objectifs
ce porte if comme je devais gagner et
gagner et gagner et si je peux
intervenir même si la question n'est pas
pour moi je suis entré dans un collectif
peu importe même si bien sûr il ya des
statuts dans une équipe en politique on
pourrait presque parler de dyarchie
c'est à dire que c'est presque un
président et son premier ministre dans
la manière dont ça a été organisé la
première question qui a été posée par un
journaliste était posée à nasser el
kadhafi et pourtant bape et tient à
prendre la parole derrière et ce qui est
très intéressant avec l'autorité c'est
que eelv à l'affirmer de manière très
subtile dans sa rhétorique l'autorité
c'est une vertu et rolls et quand on
doit préciser qu'on en a bah on n'en a
plus et justement il ya plusieurs
reprises il va réussir à la fia mais des
gens prenant la parole pour se
saisissant la balle au bond pour
exprimer ce les messages à quel point
vous avez donné les pleins pouvoirs
sportifs a acquis liane hem bape et on
sait que le projet sportif est important
dans la discussion vous avez eu depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois à quel point
il va avoir un droit de regard sur le
recrutement sur la nomination de
l'organigramme merci je reste quand même
un joueur de foot et j'irai pas au delà
de cette fonction bien sûr si on est
amené à parler football j'aime le
football à tout le monde connaît ma
passion j'aime discuter foot parler foot
mais j'irai jamais au delà de ma
fonction de joueurs de foot vous
remarquerez que le journaliste a utilisé
auprès de ma soeur elle pas d'api cette
expression qui est très politique c'est
l'expression de transfert des pleins
pouvoirs à killian m ap et m me paie se
réapproprie une terme à en répondant par
un autre pot termes politiques il dit
que en tant que joueur je n'irai pas au
delà de mes fonctions est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est le mot
politique qui vient répondre un autre
mot politique et ça c'est extrêmement
habile de sa part à un moment donné il
ya la question épineuse qui lui est
posée c'est est ce que vous voulez le
rôle de capitaine plutôt que de mettre
dans un rapport servile avec les
journalistes question posée réponse
fournie oui ou non qui sans doute aurait
pu embarrasser à ce que fait ma paie
c'est qu'il va répondre de manière
différente ses responsabilités en
question qu'elles peuvent elles être
désormais est ce que vous voulez par
exemple être le capitaine du paris saint
germain est ce que vous l'avez demandé
je pense
après avoir un peu plus de maturité que
les responsabilités ça s'acquiert sur le
terrain et je pense c'est ce que j'ai
fait après j'ai réussi à gagner le
respect de mes coéquipiers de mes
adversaires sur le terrain et je pense
que c'est de là que je vais garder le
respect il ya déjà un capitaine voilà
c'est un joueur important en plus de
notre projet j'ai pas envie de devenir
lui couper la tête comme ça cela
sous-entend au final que si ils le
voulaient ils pourraient le faire même
s'il n'exerce pas son autorité il en a
la qualité
oratoire de mba pc qu'ils s'approprient
les mous les journalistes et de ses
interlocuteurs je suis vraiment
concentré sur ce nouveau contrat
m'investir pleinement sur
sur ce nouveau projet sur cette nouvelle
ère est ce qui se passera dans le futur
je sais pas si je peux si je peux me
permettre tu sais pas où tu seras dans
un 3 en moi je sais pas peut-être aussi
mais moi je sais pas
[Musique]